[Musique]
l'argument qu'il serait sûr
pour les pirates du sexe qui
[Musique]
Je ne pense pas que ce soit bien, c'est déjà là hein
super sûr très bien organisé
Alors pourquoi allez-vous réparer quelque chose qui n'est pas
est cassé et
la nuisance vécue ici euh et
c'est vraiment là, c'est et c'est
vraiment donc hein c'est à cause des propos
le tourisme mais ce n'est pas la faute
les travailleuses du sexe
[Musique]
ça va on allait être placé je sais
pas de [ __ ] de boulot dans ta tête
parce que nous vivons dans un quartier résidentiel et que nous
veux qu'aucune nuisance ne s'abrite dans
le quartier
et beaucoup, beaucoup de jeunes enfants et
pareil et nous ne voulons pas être autorisés non plus
euh comme sur les balles
se promener
[Musique]
vraiment très dur pour tout le monde
satisfaire Il y aura toujours
il y a des protestations il y aura toujours de la résistance
choisir parmi chaque solution
[Musique]